before he even got to Helsinki President
Trump had managed to send the world's
political immediate establishments into
meltdown yes it was a vintage week for
unthinking anti Trump bigotry and hate
focusing as usual on style not substance
and ignoring as usual actual facts in
favor of condescending and uninformed
contempt for Donald Trump his supporters
and his agenda so as a public service
let's fact check the pearl clutching
chorus of elitist disapproval of the
president's European disrupter AMA but
the elitists said he weakened NATO fact
as the NATO secretary-general himself
said repeatedly it was pressure from the
president that got NATO members to cough
up more cash on top of that President
Trump has increased America's military
contribution compared to President Obama
so more money from NATO members and more
military resources from America that is
obviously strengthening NATO not
weakening it idiots
next the elitists said President Trump
was wrong to take Angela Merkel to task
over her pipeline deal with Russia but
the deal is real and really bad in fact
we first said so right here on this show
in swamp Watch months ago why is the
foreign policy establishment more upset
about President Trump pointing this out
than about the substance of the pipeline
deal itself something that really does
undermine NATO because they're blinded
by their hatred of Trump idiots
then there's brexit the president was
attacked for criticizing theresa mays
brexit plan but what he said about her
plan was true what Theresa May said
standing right next to the president was
false now they're up in arms that he
called the EU fo but it is a faux entree
exactly as the president said and not
just affirm America the --use trade
barriers keep Africa trapped in poverty
preventing some of the world's poorest
countries from improving their economies
by selling products in Europe we'll have
more on the EU and brexit later in the
show
and finally the elitists favorite topic
Russia first they were obsessed about
whether President Trump would soften
America stand
on Russia's invasion of Crimea but how
could he soften it President Obama's
attitude to Putin over Crimea was softer
than a melting ice cream in the summer
Sun he even admitted it himself look
what he told the Atlantic in 2016 if
there is somebody in this town that
would claim that we would consider going
to war with Russia over Crimea and
eastern Ukraine they should speak up and
be very clear about it the idea that
talking tough or engaging in some
military action that is tangential to
that particular area is somehow going to
influence the decision-making of Russia
or China is contrary to all the evidence
we've seen over the last 50 years and
then the new Miller indictments caused a
new bout of trump Russia collusion itis
but let's fact check those pompous
pontificate errs on the sunday shows
this morning fact the Obama
administration was fully aware of
Russia's election hacking ended
practically nothing about it fact the
Trump administration has been much
tougher on Putin than Obama ever was not
just with tougher sanctions but hitting
them where it really hurts energy policy
and fact the biggest and most dangerous
foreign government hacking of America is
being done by China for decades previous
administration's backed by the idiots in
the foreign policy establishment have
sucked up to China with President Trump
finally we're hitting back with the same
elitists who want him to unleash hell on
Russia criticizing him for standing up
to China even though China is a much
bigger threat to America I mean really
I've used the word idiots a few times
tonight and I think you can see why of
course I don't mean that disrespectfully
but in the Nassim Taleb sense the
brilliant Black Swan author coined the
phrase I why I intellectual yet idiot to
describe elitist groupthink
well we've had a bucket full of it this
week with more to come no doubt from the
general direction of Helsinki Finland
tell me what you think of all that next
rev fnc and that steve hilton x and
don't forget to pre-order your copy of
my new book positive populism
revolutionary ideas to rebuild economic
security family and community in america
you can do that at positive populism dot
org